so over the three scripts that you've
done and what was that time span again
well I've written for four on the first
three were probably a year and a half or
a year and four months yeah and where
have you seen your growth as a writer
like what what have you seen that you've
really honed in on maybe you got notes
you receive notes on them like you know
RB can you change this or this character
falls flat here and then you've really
fleshed it out um structure a little bit
certainly from the first scripted a
second script there was a big jump in
structure and i think that the you know
in refining the structure and i think
that what caused that was with the first
script I had what I thought was a good
idea but I didn't have the follow
through the whole way like you know I
was like well you know I'm going to find
the story in the middle had the ending
which changed so i was you know
receptive to going into it aside the
beginning in the ending but I really
didn't I I allowed myself too much room
kind of in the middle so the story
meandered and characters kind of came
and went and things of that nature with
the next script I didn't really outline
in the traditional sense I didn't go
this scene this the scene that or have
you know index cards or anything in that
nature but what I did was I kind of laid
out my characters and said here's here's
how they're going to grow here's because
he was my beginning and here's my ending
and here's how they're going to kind of
get from here to here ok and I'm going
to allow myself some room to go but not
so much you know and that allowed that
meat I wrote that script very very
quickly because of that like I had the
story and it flowed more freely from me
and you know so when I got to the third
script there was this idea that ok it
worked there this is completely
different story and they were two
totally different stories from second to
third but but I kind of get what works
for me now like any know I kind of get
will work but keeps me from wandering
off too far you know and I think that
was one of the biggest differences sure
you